hello and welcome to this video playing
I am zazen is best
okay let's play the score for Knights
yep and we've got the main line it's
also the best line problem there are
most of the time when you look into an
opening a little bit deeper you're going
to really find out why the main line is
the main line yeah sometimes sometimes
you have cases where wait I should
blunder stuff sometimes you have cases
where you have a like a really really
good alternative that is not the main
line but quite often it is just the best
line that you can play okay interesting
so we should leave for this should be
for Bishop f4 Bishop h7 wins upon Bishop
b4 rupee form doesn't work but so what
is he doing here okay so Bishop d6
Bishop c7 takes on e - yeah I will
probably win d2 pawn in that line I can
also take in or take with the room very
strange stuff very very strange so I was
thinking that if I put the bishop on to
e3 yeah then I did not take into account
we just maybe a mistake okay let's go
here yeah maybe maybe it is just not all
that much but here I was thinking should
be three I will win the pawn right
[Music]
give me the barn
[Music]
okay like take a seven nah doesn't
really do much greater
[Music]
maybe f3 was a was a stupid move that
was a stupid move
yeah that didn't that did not make any
sense you had to allow this thing right
okay now can you do okay Bishop d2 I
guess trade one look
yeah it's still very difficult to
imagine that you can you can win here as
always Coss this somewhat annoying
pressure on the pawn but yeah that's
what it is
okay look here Andrew give one so yeah I
don't want to go back just wanted to get
the D foul
okay so d8
yeah Bishop g4 okay let's do this first
and then we should before didn't expect
that
so I can check here and now what what's
going on so he goes to g7 yeah
must I mean have to to g8 sorry that's
why and then woke g7 king of a it
doesn't doesn't isn't that annoying
somehow yeah maybe not so much not so
much nice got discount plane
[Music]
No
ten seconds is not too comfortable 17
group g7 and ng5 it is more important
than the b-pawn iose
so g6 is probably not helping
however I don't get to play em don't get
to play g6 at all with the thing and
then you can take now on c4 okay yeah
that's going to be a draw not good it's
not good at all
it's the draw for sure actually
yeah okay yeah he has to cover if three
of Koshien okay take now that's terrible
after witness of course now those are I
think fairly easily winning ending I
notice fairly easily but I don't know I
should win this this position I should
win I mean a very odd very odd sequence
here 94 it yeah okay so this is forced
now I can move the Queen that is not
stupid at all I mean a position like
that is a little bit better for waiting
because the somewhat split pawn
structure doesn't help like it's not the
end of the world but I'm certainly a bit
better sort of what the engines has 0-3
something and this is some getting right
into this ending yeah which is probably
equal but he he gave me that pawn yeah
difficult just to keep it look a for
seems to be okay according to the engine
because of a three Ruby age okay
keep the poor okay yeah then this is
just equal but he gave me this for for
nothing much gent here I mean this is
very nice for white because the points
are still also split there were
certainly better options
Luke c6 okay that is very easy actually
can still take c6 and for some reason I
don't do it very strange okay s7 is very
stupid I wanted to get to the h6 pawn
but you can just take if you want to do
that and I mean here we're getting to
the point where just too many pawns yeah
I would have definitely at the end I
know he will get something back but I
would have two pawns at the end at least
yeah here was getting hectic and
probably it's not that great anymore I
cannot really keep the spawns and
opposite colored bishops a huge drawing
factor yeah okay guys thanks for
watching